He leaks his DMs with Hutch cuz Hutch did reach out to Quan and
actually said he would debate him and then backs out. Okay. And
Quman decides to leak the DMs, but he has to give us like his
3minut little bit of a mini rant on why exactly. I wouldn't say
I like hate watch Hush. It just happened to be that there's some
funny stuff coming out about Hutch. >> But I just want
to tell you right now, baldness is a choice, okay? It's a >> It's
a lifestyle. It's an aura. It's a vibe, okay? But it's an intentional
decision. Initially, I don't I don't like this attitude where
you go into your Discord and tag at everyone with a video critical
of you. I don't like this attitude at all. I don't go and do
gay like this. >> I don't even know who the J person is.
I don't know who this person is. Are they Are they like a regular
>> rebooting a Queenman segment? Him talking about Hutch
cuz it actually dubtales into this very very well. Okay. It does
dubtail into the next segment very well and I think it I think
it works. Okay. Okay. Queen versus Hutch. Well, this is um this
is have this had to do with apparently Hutch is now no longer
canceling on Queen, but Hutch did cancel on Queen I think two
days ago, right? He said he wasn't going to debate him. And I
do want to cover some of that stuff. So, let me take a quick
look. I grabbed a time stamp for him here.
Right there. >> Oh, yeah. I'm sure Hutch watch. >> Okay.
Okay. Okay. >> Watch my video. No, I I saw this getting
>> somebody posted so Hutch posted that he he talked to
Quimman and Quimman responded like DM and we'll talk. >> So
this is actually from Nicholas Dioro's paid Discord I believe.
Um and it's a screenshot from Hutch's Discord. So Hutch says
in his Discord
everyone, we've got some fun content to react to tomorrow. So
he never >> Yes. very fun content to react to for >> We
got to this and he linked my video >> I don't think that
Hutch actually watched the video here. Let me
>> That hasn't happened, guys. That hasn't >> Do
I have to? You know what? I'm going to let Queen >> I'm
thinking about how to handle this. Okay. I was racking my brain
for how >> we're going to I'm going to indulge here a little
bit and listen to Quman talk about why exactly he leaks these
DMs cuz he leaks his DMs with Hutch cuz Hutch did reach out to
Quean and actually said he would debate him and then backs out.
Okay. and Queen decides to leak the DMs, but he has to give us
like his three minute little bit of a mini rant on why >> Really,
I started racking my brain for how to handle this last night
before I went to sleep because I did speak to Hodge briefly before
I before I went to sleep. But this morning when I woke up, especially
I say this morning, this afternoon when I woke up, I especially
I was contemplating how do I handle this? What do I do? What
do I do in this
>> Because I don't like just leaking DMs.
Um,
unless I like know the person well, it's just like a funny inconsequential
DM and we're, you know, everyone's going to be okay with it.
I don't like just going and leaking DMs generally. >> However,
a few things leaking DMs
>> that I am DM interaction between us >> in this
case. >> A few things have for me. There's a few factors
that I'm considering here. So, I want to sort of lay out my thinking
on
>> First of all, I do think we need to
uh penalize running
pretty hard. I think that's where we can penalize running, it
should be penalized. That's number one.
>> Okay, runners. >> Number two is he was very initially
I don't I don't like this attitude where you go into your Discord
and tag at everyone with a video critical of you. >> I
don't like this attitude at all. I don't go and do gay like this.
I don't like this attitude whatsoever where you go and you >> It's
very techone coded. Okay. I feel like Techone when he knows that
there's like a reaction video or some video about him that sucks,
he'll like he'll like say, "Oh, look, we got this." Or uh who
else? Techone stopped doing this, but when he didn't have big
ones, when he did have like big actual allegations, he used to
do this all the time. He's kind of falling off of it a little
bit. >> Everyone, we've got some fun content to react to
tomorrow.
>> It's kind It's pretty >> Nobody owes you a conversation,
buddy. Well, that's not That's true. Nobody owes you a conversation,
but like Hutch literally said he was going to watch it and react
to it. And then Hutch literally me or put put Yeah. put up a
tweet saying, "Hey, I talked to this guy. Who's this guy? I talked
to this guy." And then Queen said, "Sure, DM me." And then they
>> You know,
>> Reban Ruben donated $3. Is it me or does Queman's voice
not match what he really looks like? >> No, I think it
matches, but maybe I'm
maybe I'm crazy. I think it matches >> behavior. It's I'm
not even It's like It is kind of lowkey brigading. I don't really
care about that aspect of it. It's just kind of like It just
comes off very insecure. It's just like you're going you're running
into your Discord hug box to at everyone like someone's talking
about me right now. Like you you look like kind of a you do kind
of look like a massive
um so I don't like that attitude. So that's the first two things.
Now third thing I've heard that he said
someone reached out to tell him about me. Now he didn't say that
to me. So that's all. >> Oh, somebody behind the scenes
got informed on Queman.
>> Um I I heard this uh I heard people talk about who this
could possibly be for a while. Okay. Who could possibly reached
out?
Lots of people would say Dan. I don't think Dan would do that.
I don't think Dan really cares about the the politics stuff and
I don't think he would have reached out to Hutch to be like,
"No, don't don't talk to Queenman." Arite probably Arerite is
like more the more likely choice. Um, Aerodator or Nick, they
they don't like Hutch. They hate Queen. Sorry, they like Hutch.
They hate Queman.
They hate Queman. Straight raid, absolutely 0% chance at straight
raid.
Um, trust me, 0% chance at straight raid. Straight raid, uh,
straight raid gets along with Queen just fine. Queen raids straight
raid all the time. They have a good relationship. Straight raid
would never go and like try to cut his legs out. 0% chance. sort
of a discrepancy
uh between those two which is which is bothersome and also I
really really dislike this attitude of going around behind oh
don't talk to that guy don't talk to that guy why why talk to
me why won't talk to me why whoever's telling you not to talk
to me this is uh this is very much in line with what not so actually
says publicly in some cases too I don't know if you guys remember
the moral smiley face chat messages when she said she would never
let Chudlo logic onto anything else right right like I will do
anything I can to prevent Chudlogic from being on anything else.
Morals, smiley face. What's your problem with Chud? Morals, smiley
face. This is very in line with like what she actually tries
to do. When are you going to stop obsessing about Kyla? Do you
mean accurately criticizing her behavior and statements? In which
case, uh, never because she says so many crazy things.
As soon as she stops being so funny to watch, I will stop criticizing.
Right. That's that's when it could happen.
should say in public why they told you not to talk to me, what
their basis is, and then when they say inevitably it's bad faith,
they should give an example and explain explain how I was wrong
in that case. Um, >> that that's what I would like to say.
I don't like this attitude. Oh, don't don't talk to this guy.
Don't talk to this guy. That's [__] bad. And the
final reason, and this is really the most important reason why
I'm deciding to delete these DMs. >> Oh, what would the
final reason be?
showing the flip or showing like the uh Hold on. The final reason
is going to be funny and I think it's going to be something like
I haven't watched I haven't watched this yet. I feel like it's
going to be him calling out Hutch's like cringe language. Hutch
calls him like a lord and Queen's like what the does that mean?
And Hutch doesn't clarify. Like it takes him forever to clarify.
Queen's like very very confused about what he means. >> Um
it's because of how he acted in the DMs. It's because of how
he acted more than anything. It's the DMs are very embarrassing
for him. Yeah, that's what it's going to be. >> And that's
pretty much the deciding factor here. >> I tal I talked
to him. So I I knew a little bit though. I didn't watch this,
but I knew a little bit cuz that was the thing he was like in
DMs mad about the most. Look at this. He's like talking to me.
He's like, "Look at this. Not what the [__] is this
[__] lord? What does this mean?" Yeah, >> I
just I knew that was going >> I want to go over these.
Okay, guys. I'm going to talk about Hutch a little bit more as
we go over these. Dev SFO in chat says, "I have only one impression
of Hutch. We're on panel together. He liked what I said and did
that soy snapping thing. Did not believe he was a real person.
You might feel that again in a moment, Dev. You might feel that
again. >> The triple snap.
>> I can do the triple snap. Oh, you you like lose oils
on on a finger and then after you snap enough and it's hard to
>> Well, damn.
>> Let's just have a little look at what you said. I'm
just trying to line these up well with my with my camera.
If I can get my trackpad to work and do a little zoom
right now. No such luck. This is why, okay, Quan was like, "Oh,
you can buy a way cheaper Windows trackpad." Uh, yeah, but why
would you do that when you could buy an Apple Magic Trackpad
that works 100% of the time and is one of the greatest pieces
of hardware ever invented? It's only like four times the price.
Just pay four times the price. 100 like 200 bucks. Get it done.
>> There we go. There we go. >> Uh, Zu, I don't know
if I'm going to read the new Destiny Core docs on stream tonight
or not. There's a lot of content. There's just a lot of this.
>> we're going to go through and analyze what happened
here. So Hutch reaches out after my Twitter reply and he says,
"Are you free tomorrow?" I'm available from 9:30 a.m. Pacific
until around 1:00 p.m. Okay, good start. That's cool. Now, I'm
not available at those times. I usually start uh stream about
1:00 p.m. Pacific. That's usually the earliest I'll start streaming
at is 1:00 p.m. Pacific. Usually more like 2. So that that's
not really very good for me. I say I'm not really available to
stream till it's 1:00 p.m. 1 p.m. Pacific most days. Are you
free any later at some point or is that your limit? Can try to
start >> So I just want to point out somebody said nobody
owes you a conversation earlier. This isn't really being owed
a conversation, right? This is Hutch wanted a conversation, wanted
to talk to this guy, and then now he's like, "Oh, so once he
cancels, but like obviously he's like making time. He's he's
going to move it. He's going to actually make sure he's able
to talk to this guy." >> Anything else? I'm trying to be
accommodating. I'm trying to make sure this happens. Trying to,
you know, make sure that even if there's a problem on his side
of the time, he knows he knows I'm here. He knows I'm I'm willing.
Okay.
I have a thing tomorrow, but I can do 1 p.m. Pacific on Monday.
So, the thing he had that day was was a wake panel about Israel
Palestine. I understand. You had a pre pre-booked wick panel.
I understand. Don't let me get away your week panel. Seriously.
So,
so I say you good with 1:30? That's more like my usual start
stream starting time. I'm like, okay, I need to that why I make
sure I've got time to like prep and not prep as in prep for the
debate, but you know, prep my stream and be ready, be be awake,
have my coffee, all that stuff. He says, sure. Okay, great. Nice.
I've seen debates over Discord. I'm just going on that. And I
follow up with, let me know if you want to limit specific topics
or anything like that. If you want to debate something in particular
or just talk through disagreements, I don't mind. So, I'm trying
to lay out here. If you've got specific terms you want for this
debate, specific topics you want to go touch or don't want to
touch, tell me now. Let's let's have that discussion now so that
when we have the conversation there can't be any confusion. No
one can be like I'm being ambushed or any crazy [__]
like that. Not that I didn't necessarily do that but just you
know I'm trying to I'm trying to make sure we hash everything
out before we start the conversation just to make sure we're
we're perfect. We're perfectly set. >> So
he says this is fine. I figured we would debate my boldness and
general cringe shitness in response to your videos. Okay. Figure
this is joking. Figure it just like you know
>> around here. Yeah. We're going to debate boldness. Yeah.
Haha. Epic. You know, like sure, no topics said. I guess you
haven't watched my video yet. You're just like posting it in
your Discord because you're like, "Oh, someone's hating on me,
guys. Come check out this person hating on me." You don't even
know what was said in it yet. You're asking to debate without
knowing the criticisms. You might agree with them fully, but
you're you're just going through the debate. I just don't get
it. Like, he was doing sort of like a weird posturing thing,
but he doesn't even know what was said.
Okay. Wait, really? What? What? >> Oh, dude. What is this
music in the background? What is happening? >> Those are
screenshots.
>> Not a fan. There's one more screenshot of his DMs. Let
me speed speed forward. Okay, speed forward. Speed forward. Here
we go. Here we go. >> So, so I leave it there. I don't
reply to that. I'm like, "Okay, this guy's like, you know, I
guess no specific topics. I leave it there. I don't I don't know
what else to say to that." You know, it doesn't seem like we've
got any specific topics, so we'll just go on to the debate. So,
but he messages back later on. Okay. Like 24 hours later, he
says, "Wait, so you're like a I initially thought you were interested
in politics. I have absolutely zero desire to do stuff." So,
I don't really know what it means by this. I don't know what
a is. I think the last time I heard would have been in like 2013
listening to Yog's cast videos where they would do as a porative.
That that's like about that's that's probably my last memory
of someone saying.
>> So there like this now I I am trapped in DMs with this
40-y old man using the term. I've got no idea what it means.
I'm like >> what a >> I don't know what you're asking
me. Can you talk like a human being >> But further more
than that he he says I thought you were actually interested in
politics. Now, if you just glance at my channel, my second channel,
you can you can very quickly see I am interested, but I put out
stuff on politics all the time. I like talking about politics.
I like joking around about it as well. I like making fun of people
and and ripping on people's content while I'm talking about politics,
but I definitely touch on on politics quite a lot. So, I don't
really know. So, I'm either So, we're drawing a distinction here.
Like there's like a dichotomy between people who are and people
are interested in politics. You can't apparently can't be both.
I I don't know necessarily what is, but I'm understanding in
Hush's view these are uh in a dichotomy. You can't you cannot
be both. You're either or interested in politics. So, I'm not
trying to figure out exactly what I'm being asked to. I have
absolutely zero desire to do stuff. It's like you're laying down
pretty firmly here. Like, this is actually this it doesn't feel
like you're really asking me a question here. You're not actually
asking me if I'm a or whatever that means. You're not actually
asking me that. You've decided you don't want to do this conversation
anymore. And you are now trying to come up with a way of asking
me a question that will give you the pretext to to back out without
actually revealing the reason you're backing out. Right? Because
I was have a conversation. I apologize. You just go gone to the
video. I watched it. I I pulled out about you. You could just
go see what things are in there. That's my politics obviously,
but you but you didn't. But apparent you didn't do that. Um so
it it does just come come off as like a little bit disingenuous
to me. I'm like, okay. So I say, "No idea what you mean by that.
I mainly cover drama and sometimes politics/jent topic." >> I
hate that. I kind of agree with Quimman here. What's a lord?
Yeah, he should have just said what his problem was, right? Like
literally just say exactly what your problem is and then they're
like if you just give a fact. Hey, you did uh you did like this
kind of content. I didn't like it because,
you know, I feel like you lied about this. If you give an actual
critique, then nobody has to like nobody can call you out. Nobody
can be like, "Oh, you like if he said, oh, you covered this Destiny
stuff and you laughed at the fact you Oh, here's one.
You You asked somebody to ask Destiny if he was I don't like
that. I don't like that kind of content. I don't like people
who do that. I don't want to talk to you now." Queen would go,
"Oh, okay." Like that seems like that is a thing I did and it
is like offensive and it is inflammatory and
sure. Yeah, absolutely. Is a weak justification to leak DMs.
It seems Queen just wanted to embarrass Hutch. Okay. I think
I think calling somebody out for being like kind of duplicitous
and and drawing attention to people with your career behind the
scenes is fine.
>> you talk like a human, please. Don't talk like a person.
Please explain what you mean. So he says stuff not serious memes
there's there's all stops there stuff period not serious period
memes period you mean am I going to troll you like what's what
are you asking right now it's very he's a very serious guy hutch
okay listen destiny adjacent political commentary is serious
business and Hutch takes it as such okay it's very serious business
>> this is like another yeah this is like another thing
where
oh man do we pull this up too where Where's my Where's my hutch
clip?
Hold on. Uh uh uh uh hold on. Where is this? Where is this? Where
is this? I need to find this this one specific
There's like a specific tweet about
basically saying that like I I regret how I commented on the
Destiny thing. And it's like I don't know why you'd do that if
you weren't looking to you know potentially collab in the future.
Hutch kind of did this immediately after Destiny defended him
from some critiques uh from the Vanguard and from some of his
like uh some of his fellow panelists on Live and Learn, right?
Yeah. He said said he regrets saying anything at all. Now, I'm
not going to say that means he's definitely like collabing with
Destiny or whatever. I'm not going to say that, but I I I just
it's like I don't know what what did you say that you regret?
I just would love to know what you regret saying there, right?
Yeah, that would be very interesting to >> Don't engage
in any. Okay. They just they bring down the rep. All right, we
can't we can't make it seem seem unserious by engaging with Okay,
I'm I'm going to be a part by the DNC one day. I want to be I
want to be a canvasing organizer one day. I want to have my own
canvasing house where I can invite a bunch of college kids to
to stay for 6 weeks. This is very serious. I need to look after
my reputation. Could not possibly care less about that stuff.
So, so I say that's not clear to me. Uh Jesus Christ, that's
not much clearer to be honest. Are you asking if I actually give
my opinions? If so, then yes.
I joke around a lot also if that's what you're asking. So, I
thought I'm getting across pretty well here. like, yeah, there's
like a >> Okay, we've got the actual tweet here.
this is um the timing on this. >> I've been thinking about
the Destiny situation a little bit more, guys. I've been thinking
about that situation a little bit more. >> Alert. Okay.
Better. >> I don't regret. >> I think that's inflammatory
and unnecessary. Guys, you don't have to call this guy B. What
>> distancing myself from something that was very radioactive.
Like, every creator has to consider their own reputation and
their own like brand.
Um, that's not a moral moral calculation. It's just that's like
a necessary calculation that every creator has to make.
>> What I do think I regret was like talking about it in
detail.
>> I think looking back I wish I would >> I just
I hate like I hate this without reasoning behind it. Maybe he
did give reasoning and it's clipped off, but like what is the
reasoning for disliking? Like what comment did you make that
was out of place or what fact did you observe or comment on that
you found out is like not correct now right like what has changed
around this that makes you go oh I feel like this
all I would love to know what's changed right it's just a weird
thing to say it's not like he yeah I would just be interested
to know would have just put that space and just not talked about
it >> I've been thinking about the
anyway we continue >> joking kind of comedy bible at the
time >> did you know he talked to food chips about this
food chops about this today. No, I saw it last night, but that
is why we're watching this so we can go into that. Don't spoil.
We're Trust me, there's an arc to all the content here and it
eventually leads to the Willy Mac stuff, okay? So, don't worry
about it. >> But I'm giving opinions, you know, we're going
on a journey. You're all with me for the journey. We're on the
journey. >> And he says, "Your content is a bit too for
the kind of conversations. Go with God." Sorry, I'm reading that.
It's not actually my fault cuz he does say, "Your content is
a bit too for the kinds of conversations. Go with God. Salute
emoji." So now it's not just Okay, so this is like I was really
like, "Okay, I'm going to show these DMs cuz this is just crazy.
This is crazy, bro. Get off your high horse, you self-s serious
bull loser. You're you're so embarrassing saying like this. Your
content is a bit too for which you mean these these kinds of
conversations. Go with God. Salute, dude. Shut the up. What do
you content is too for these kinds of conversations?" Asmin Gold
is the biggest commentator on the internet right now. Are you
>> And again, you would talk to Destiny. You did cut him
off because of the stuff. So, I don't even know.
And like also, if it's a person,
sorry, if it's like a person,
I would look at their political conversations and just like would
you should you not be able to have like a solid win on political
topics against this person if he if he doesn't do any politics?
Feels like it should be easy. Honestly, when you pull Destiny
and all his orbiters apart, they all aside one or two, Destiny
excluded, show they are they demonstrated intellect together,
but individually they're weak and dumb. Um maybe like when you
argue, you can obviously like sharpen opinions and points and
stuff and and be better. That's true.
I posted this yesterday.
The Hutch exit execute thing is just very funny. Okay, that's
not my fault. That's not my fault that it's funny. I didn't make
it funny. It's just funny. Okay. On its own. On its own. It's
Hutch is Hutch is the cracked egg. Is his egg is cracking. Okay.
>> Would jump at any opportunity to debate that guy. No.
You've got you've got some other excuse to not.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You jump at any you you dude.
This guy gets what 400, 500, 600 viewers concurrent sometimes
and you can totally own him in a conversation. Yeah. Get in there.
your ear or something like that and you've decided you're not
doing it because you're worried about how it might go or how
it might look to your friends or something like that and you're
being a
for these kinds of conversations. Get a it's not even like it's
it's too for me. I'm trying to be more serious for these kinds
of conversations, bro. Get a grip. It's the internet, bro. You're
a 500 viewer internet politics streamer. It ain't that deep,
bro. It really ain't that deep. Okay, it really is not.
And so I reply and this is he doesn't reply to this running and
I do uh bald old man emoji person running emoji. Uh pop a smoke
emoji.
>> So that's where that's where communication ended. Okay.
That's where communication ended. Exactly.
>> Is there anything else in the hutch >> I've been
thinking about that situation a little bit more. >> Yeah.
Oh, Quinn literally plays the uh the stuff. >> What did
he say about originally I
>> Oh, he's going to go and take a look at it. You know,
I originally I also the reason why this is happening, by the
way, is because he had he had two debates recently that went
pretty poorly for him. He had a debate on Live and Learn where
they brought on these guys called the Vanguard. Now, one of them
was really dumb. One of them was slightly less dumb, but Hutch
wasn't really like he keeps saying, "Oh, I want to get him. I
want to get him some." The real chat >> it's uh Desi did
a video reacting to it and like totally took Hutch's side and
like blew Hutch up, which is like, "Yeah, this guy this guy's
the only smart person here. He's the only one getting it right
here." Right. That was how it went. >> Challenge to Hutch
in that conversation. Wasn't the Vanguard guys. It was Pisco
and Josiah. Pisco and Josiah were obviously trying to sort of
stalem the position of the Vanguard guys to Hutch and Hutch was
shutting down, not engaging, looking. >> Okay. Apparently
Hutch talked about this on stream today.
>> Do we want to see that? Hutch talked about it on stream
today.
>> I'll take a look at it on stream today. We We'll look
at this. >> trust me. This is all leading somewhere, guys.
Okay. This is all leading to the Willie stuff. >> Yeah.
So, he does like a lot of drama content, but he also talks about
politics.
And I was originally going to have a conversation with him and
then somebody reached out in private and and described him as
uh basically like like a bad faith troll and that made me not
want to do it. >> Wow. Like just a bad just a total bad
faith troll. >> Um
yeah, >> again just show the bad faith examples,
right? Just show the examples of bad faith. Where where in a
conversation is he being bad faith? Just show me any examples.
Any examples at all? Any examples at all? No. Does Hutch know
you food drops me? Yeah, we're we're getting >> Are you
saying that like would you say he's good faith? Would you say
like if you if you approach a conversation in good faith, he'll
reciprocate or does it always devolve into like memes and blah
blah blah? >> I I would say that he is absolutely good
faith. He's always been a debate guy. He's
uh he originally came up during the um like he was somebody who
would call into streams during the Twitch poll days
like he and he sort of emerged from
where they would like frequently talk to all kinds of different
people and as you know like Chad is somebody who
um emerged from
Twitch poll and Twitch poll was very adjacent. All right, I'm
uh I'm full on free booting this for like 90 seconds while I'll
be right back. Uh just give me two two minutes or something.
Two or three minutes. It's teeny tiny Tony. Oh well, if it's
teeny tiny Tony, then he's going to have positive opinions of
Quan, right? This might be where they get Queen back in the in
the debate sphere here. The only thing is Queman is becoming
such a force to debate or converse with for those who disagree.
He'd getting Well, that's kind of true. That's true. Cyberdrifter,
I just wish there there like should be a guide to debating people
like this. Queen is very good at debating, but what he'll do
on topics he really cares about is he will engage in like a framing
where real realistically the answer has to be you have to think
long and hard about whether or not you want to disagree with
what he's saying or change what he's saying, right? Because what
he'll do is he'll make it so his claim is like basically a priori
correct, right? But he'll say the claim in a way that makes it
sound like he's being a little more hyperbolic. Yeah. It's uh
it's not a M and Bailey though. It's not that. I don't know how
to explain it. It's like the the framing is incredibly important
to how you win debates, right? And Queen is very good at getting
people upset and to get engaged with like his framing or his
his criticism which within like the the frame of that being the
criticism is very difficult to defend against >> to Destiny
very much like
you know he was a former Destiny viewer as well. >> Um
and he's always had an interest in debate. He always
>> is very happy to talk to people from his chat with disagreements.
Um, he's talked to me uh twice. I think I've called into his
stream and had disagreements. And he's very um he's very willing
to hear you out. He also like he does have a drama focus and
he likes to, you know, he is a memer like he likes to make jokes
and things, but um he also
like he'll stake out a position and then logically try to walk
through why he's holding that position on this particular drama.
and >> he would be more than happy to talk with somebody
who um has a disagreement and wants to argue about like the specifics
of the drama. >> Um for me that's part of why I like drama
cuz sort of you know everybody has the information in front of
them and you can argue about it. >> Well, we we we certainly
agree uh we certainly disagree about one thing. Hang on, let
me put it on the screen. Okay, I don't mind political disagreements.
Okay. But I just want to tell you right now,
baldness is a choice. Okay? It's a >> is a choice. >> It's
a lifestyle. It's an aura. It's a vibe. Okay? But it's an intentional
>> Okay? So, I just >> I think >> I'm just
saying, >> well, I uh I commend you for choosing to accept
baldness rather than uh chasing hair with stuff like finasteride
or stuff like that. And I think uh Greein would probably agree
with that.
But um I also want to say that Queman does a lot of political
content pretty much every day.
Um like he covers political topics regularly.
He >> Well, now I uh I just dropped and shattered a glass.
Unfortunately, I just went and got a drink, dropped and shattered
a glass. Now I have to clean that up. Give me like another three
four minutes. debated lonerbox recently for two hours talking
about anti-semitism
on
coming from leftwing political people. >> Uhhuh. Is he
leftwing? Is he like a socialist or is he a liberal or what is
>> He's leftwing. He um >> Yeah, but what what kind
of leftwinger?
>> Yeah. Uh he's probably pretty close to you politically.
>> Oh, okay. Um, in terms of like like he I would expect
that he would always vote Labor in the UK.
Um, he's obviously
despises Trump, thinks he's terrible.
>> I can't transform it. >> Listen, I I I
>> don't know what to do here for two seconds. I'm going
to let Hutch go. Uh, it sucks, but I'll just give me two >> I
think I am. Yeah, I'm I'm willing to have a conversation with
I had a couple people tell me like, "No, no, no. He it can be
a good fifth conversation." So, as long as that's the case, then
I'm
>> Yeah. Well, it it can absolutely be a good faith conversation.
I think it would be a good idea. >> Okay, I'll do it. Yeah,
I'll have a conversation with Yeah, >> that sounds awesome.
>> All right. Well, good talking to you. >> Yeah.
Thanks. Thanks for talking to me. >> All right. Byebye.
>> All right. We got one more and then we're going to get
into some stuff. KJ Frankie, thanks so much for the primer.
Hope your day is going great. Heart rate down. Uh, and then there
might have been a Hold on. Pisco wants to have a conversation
about is Pisco live right now. He want He want We he wants to
I want to pick up where we left off last night. We'll we're going
to do a live and learn postmortem. He's not good faith lol. But
it would be content and Hutch would destroy in any political
debate. Well, don't say that. Listen,
this is a topic that I feel very comfortable debating just because
I just feel very strongly about it and I feel like the the the
uh the arguments just are so strong um that I just don't I feel
just yeah I don't think I don't think I would have a hard time
debating anybody on this topic just because it feels like the
arguments themselves are so strong. Um but you know
Lonerbox is a pretty good debater. You know I I put I wouldn't
want to be on the other end of a debate with Lonerbox. That's
the other thing about Kuiman. Is that his name? Kuiman. That's
the other thing about Kuiman was like I got a sense from his
community that it's a very um
eccentric crowd which can be kind of >> it is something
of an eccentric eccentric crowd. I'd say that's that's probably
true. Okay, I'm back. God, that was annoying. Sorry about that,
guys. Sorry about that. Sorry about that. That was uh that's
not great. That's not >> Like a bit much, you know. Um,
okay. Moving from here. Okay. So, Hutch does decide maybe that
he would talk to Queen again.
Last night though, okay, last night after saying he wouldn't
talk to Queen because Queen is a Hutch ended up in the strangest
of places. Okay. The absolute strangest of places.
And that was
on a food shop stream. Yeah. On a food shop stream. >> I
got curious.
Now
why why and how and why?
So basically Queman okay
can't talk to that guy. Okay
openly someone who openly has expressed their their feeling that
they have uh obsessivempulsive disorder POCD. Okay. This person
we'll put them we'll put them in the coalition. Okay.
So hold on. Let me see. I'm I don't know exactly how I put this.
I put this in a chat somewhere. Hold on. There we go. This is
my comment in a different discord. One second. Imager, please.
Imager, please.
This is Hutch's tier list of evil. Okay. Number one. Number two.
Number three. Quan.
Actually, there should be a dot dot dot here because we don't
know how how many other people are there. But then all known.
Okay.
Could not possibly reach out to Quimman and speak to him. But
this person who's talked about how they explicitly like the idea
of like having power over a very a minor to force them to have
with them. Okay, that that person we put them in the lip coalition.
Okay, welcome to the lip coalition, brother. I've heard we shouldn't
purity test too much. Okay, we're going to purity test on people
who are quote unquote. But you know what? We won't purity test
on
We won't purity test on your obsession with minors. Okay, your
obsession with minors. We won't we won't purity test on that.
So, I just I don't get how you end up on the food shop stream
when you say you couldn't talk to Queen, but it's okay. Well,
I do know how. Um, it's Hutch Defense Squad, right? We're defending
Hutch from everybody. >> So, like, yeah. What's What's
your story? What how >> context? The context is Hutch do
a de with Queen canceled with him and then the very same night
within 24 hours was went on food shop stream to just chat. >> you
get involved in >> Very interesting.
>> Oh,
okay. Sure. I'm going to pull a white man here and then do my
life my life story. Why not? Sorry, I'm a little bit nervous.
Holy. Okay. Um,
>> I don't know. >> Wait, what? I just got linked
to a food shops clip. What is this? What is this clip? Oh, hold
on. I got to go to stream >> I'm just being chilling. I
think um I discovered Destiny back then uh >> being chilling
>> a couple of times um locally. not with Destiny but canvas
locally just because um I was influenced by that kind of sphere
I've been doing >> feels like someone set him up. I don't
know how this happened to be honest with you. Like whoever that
person is who was like no no don't don't talk to Quebin I I don't
know content creation for
one and a half years. Um otherwise I came out as a pretty controversial
figure. Um just mainly because of past traumas and such but you
know it's uh it is whatever. Um otherwise you know I've got a
strong following and a good community and otherwise I'm kind
of a secret content creator you know. But >> and like like
what do you like what do you um when you look at politics right
now? Like what are >> Thank you. within 24 hours. So show
me how Hutch knew food shops PDF take or whatever. Oh, I'm not
saying that he knew. I think in fact it's probably pretty obvious
he didn't know. Simpo.
I hope you I hope you don't think like this is humor, right?
The imager thing that I just had up. That's humor obviously.
But I'm saying somebody wanted to give Hutch a heads up saying,
"Hey, just so you know, don't talk to Queenman. this guy's bad
faith. But they couldn't go, "Hey, also don't talk to this person.
They're they've made some weird statements on stream, okay? You
don't want you don't want your brand associated with them." Hold
on. What is this? What is this? Is a food shops clip, apparently.
>> And then watch this. >> Wait, why don't I have
video here? What is going on?
>> Yeah, you guys can't see video. What the happened?
The hell?
>> The video is not working. Okay, this is
Uh, how do I get this to work? I don't know how to get it. Oh,
it's them doing a photoshop of them and Queenman hugging.
Oh boy.
Wait, the audio or the video won't work. This is weird as I'll
I'll fix it. Give me two seconds. I'll go back to this. We'll
go back to this. Keep listening to them. >> What are some
of the observations you have about like this this moment in the
zeitgeist? I I think it's frustrating
when I was canvasing back then um you have a Why does Hutch look
perpetually
His eyes seem like he's in a constant state of fightlight.
I don't know. Somebody posted this under my uh Let me find it.
Somebody posted this meme under the blastoff tweet. It's just
like
good times. It's always good times.
We're just having We're just having good times here. All right.
>> Okay. Hold on. Does this work? Did this There we go.
>> And then watch this. >> You want You want stronger
colors? Watch >> Qu shops.
>> Qu shops.
>> Okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay, dude. Now, if you don't know, uh, Queman and food
shops were like sort of shipped together for a long time in spicy
chat, like about a year and a half ago.
Uh, I I get raids from Quean and they do like the and they throw
like a cat face, like an anime cat face in my chat. Okay, there's
a whole meme people were doing for a while. Also, I 100% believe
Dest is trying to wedge Hutch from the commies on Li and Learn
try trying to pour gas on the rifts. Yeah, he absolutely is.
Yep,
How do I not know about this? Well, it wasn't something that
was like a big deal before, but it's just kind of funny now.
People have these memes kicking around. Okay.
>> A lot of people who are
liberals and lefties who do care about politics, and I have seen
them form a coalition together, right, as you said. Um, and we
have people who openly who go doorto-door canvasing to vote despite
calling themselves
uh like calling themselves socialists. Okay. I mean, maybe a
couple of years later, maybe things have changed. But it seems
as though um there has to be a differentiation made between leftists
who actually care about coalition building versus whoever this
person that you're debating right now who is just very clearly
treating it as like a social club. Um, if the >> what is
he talking about? Is he are they talking about the Vanguard people?
>> Algorithm has presented me to you, then it must mean
that there really is nobody out there but me
like you do. I don't know, dude. Um, that's definitely not true
saying. Yeah, go ahead. >> No, that's that's definitely
not true. I get a lot of emails from people these days, like
a lot. Um, so I I think there's an appetite for,
you know, like I I I don't want to use my big voice and get angry
and and and be mean in that side of that sort of thing. Uh, it
just feels like
to me it feels like in this day and age, you have to
like there's so much anger from that side and there's so many
unchallenged kind of orthodoxies and narratives. >> I feel
like you have to you have to get a little bit aggressive. But
in the case of like Ogre Boy, that guy is just >> he I
mean he was in my >> in the case of Ogre Boy. Ogre boy
is the true villain. Okay. Ogre boy is the true villain, guys.
>> He he was in my chat every day like with the most insane
accusations. So like >> yeah, Ogre boy is in my chat every
day with the most insane accusations. Like Hutch ran from me.
>> That was not in a vacuum. Like I got super aggro with
that guy because he's super bad faith. So >> why didn't
you ban him like at the very >> Um
I I don't know. I feel like for the content I would It was >> Oh,
for the content. Like there's there's a lot of like conflict
in my chat sometimes, especially on Twitch. On YouTube, it's
a lot more chill because I'm like building up a new community
there. But okay, >> on Twitch there's a lot of um >> like
I used to be big big into that whole space like I got along with
like Needle Drop and Hassan and Mike from PA and like all those
guys because we all opposed Trump and supported Bernie in the
primaries and then once Bernie got >> hold on Needle Drop
was an Anthony
>> Yeah. Yeah, I don't know if we ever interacted, but
I think like we followed each other on Twitter and maybe like
I retweeted him a couple times or what, but like I'm just saying
like I was in that space and then everything kind of changed
after Bernie lost in 2020 cuz I immediately I immediately was
like, "Okay, Biden was the guy. I just I'm not going to get hung
up about this." And they never really let that go, I don't
>> Yeah, dude. Is it true that Ogre Boy has a Hassan tattoo?
>> oh.
Ogre Boy does have a Hassan tattoo. That is very true. He does
have a a Hassan tattoo. Um, listen,
getting tattoos of content creators, that's very cringe. But
also, Ogre Boy will come on. He's like one of the few like far-left
people who will go on like anywhere and talk about his beliefs
and engage honestly. So, I'm willing to let go of the tattoo
for like temporarily
while he's engaging in good faith with people while he is actually
I wouldn't even say always good faith. I'd say him not wanting
to engage with Putch's hypothetical wasn't the best, but I think
he mostly it was mostly
in line with like having a good faith conversation, okay, with
Hutch. Mostly
uh Space Ghost, thank you very much for the gifted sub. Appreciate
it, buddy. >> I think so. I haven't seen it, but I I've
heard >> like a like a permanent
tattoo like >> Yeah, he does,
>> He does. Cuz I'm not going to judge tattoos, but Yeah.
No, he does. Yeah. I I feel like I feel like I wouldn't even
tell someone to get like like I would even advise a friend of
mine to not get a tattoo of their significant other, you know,
just in case one day you might break up or something, right?
But like the fact that you get like a Hassan tattoo is is um
crazy work, I have to >> Um yeah. >> Yeah. I I think
gosh, I I think a lot with a lot of these leftists online, I
think they use politics as an avenue to have a digital social
life. I think that's what's going on.
Same with streamers. Okay, there are there are many streamers,
possibly the one we're looking at now that does not want a regular
social life, is looking for a digital one. >> I think that
they circle around the >> concept of leftism, like communism
and >> Sick monkey chamber thing for the 11 >> Find
Discord servers that they can hang out in. Um, pretend that they
know what they're talking about, but
>> hey, aren't we all a little guilty?
Um, I don't actually see them going out and doing things. Um,
I actually respect people who call themselves lefties and actually
go out and do things. For example, back in college, I used to
have this IRL friend who uh was a Vos fan of all things, right?
And considering how much we would probably disagree like like
agree on how Vosch is and how much I disagree with that lefty
about Vosch um he basically joined um the city's uh city planning
board with a bunch of boomers and arguing against boomers in
terms of yimism versus nimiism all day right um and to me that
is extremely impressive like like that level of political activism
by a lefty is immensely impressive so like that I go online and
I just see a lot of these people who um hate watch you like Jeremia
all these people right like Okay, so apparently I hate watch
Hutch. I engage with Hutch along the lines of like I was watching
other stuff and then Hutch was getting to fights. Like I watch
some of the Lib and Learn stuff just to watch it, right? I've
watched other people on Live and Learn. I wouldn't say I like
hate watch Hutch. It just happened to be that there's some funny
stuff coming out about Hutch. Um they hate >> I don't even
know who the J person is. I don't know who this person is. Are
they Are they like a regular You >> sure you don't know
who this
>> I don't know who this is. I actually believe him, by
the way. I totally believe that he might not know who I am. That's
believable. >> The I mean, he's um he he he was previously
one of the biggest or not biggest orbiters, but he orbited Destiny
and then after
after the whole Destiny League scandal dropped. Um J Stoke basically
said, "Okay, I'm going to burn my bridge of Destiny and start
making anti- Destiny hate streams."
you could frame it that way.
You could frame it that way, but I I don't know why this is like
the most framing because I didn't do the primary action that
burns the bridge.
Okay. The the action for me that burns the bridge is when I find
out that the person I stream with six days a week, like six to
eight hours a day for months and months and months, when I find
out that you non-consensually recorded them in a situation and
then distributed that without their consent. There's just no,
they had no idea this was happening. Yeah. That's when I'm like,
"Oh, you're a total piece of [__] that burns the
bridge with me. Why Why do we Why do we have this guy commit
these like awful acts and then people are like, "Oh, wow. It's
really weird that people would burn the bridge with him after
that. That's so weird. That's so weird.
>> I No, I I don't know. I don't know who this person is.
Like I was never
>> People would like I had >> I didn't even see Wait,
that's the way that's phrased. It's like you saw a content gap
and decided to capitalize rather than had a huge moral issue.
>> Uh that's also true. Yeah, sure. >> I had I mean,
listen, I was friendly with Destiny. I had like maybe >> we
we chatted maybe eight times on stream. Um, people would people
would call me an orbiter and I've been like doing this for a
really long time. So, I never like that label cuz I just don't
I'm I'm my own like person and that sort of thing. But I I Yeah.
Is the JO do they watch my stuff a lot? Should I like hit them
up and like have a >> I think I think I think listen listen
I I'm a drama slop tuber, okay? So, I advocate for anything that
maximize
this content. >> So, apparently they're just going to say
go argue. It gives me something to farm, but it might not go
well for you. I don't bunch of people burnt the bridge with DMER
after you killed all those people that dude that that's the exact
same hypothetical I use in some other situations. Okay. Um I
think depending on where I go, I didn't get a chance to write
a lot of this stuff down. I kind of want to go grab some clips
and do some actual writing on this, but basically there were
people who within like a week of this happening came out and
were like, "Oh, here's the path to Destiny's Redemption. Okay,
here's the path to Desessie's project. Here's how Desi could
redeem himself. Arrodite was the one where she's like, "This
is what I would need to see from him in order to like keep working
with him or think he's a good person or whatever, right?
One, nobody talks about redemption for a serial killer like the
day they're caught before any evidence is analyzed, right? Like
that just seems weird. How do we redeem this person when we don't
know exactly how far this goes? We know nothing. We're like out.
We're totally out of the loop. We don't know what else would
come out, right? It's very bizarre. very very bizarre in my opinion.
Okay. Also, for all the things Arerodite said she needed to see
from Destiny for him to be redeemed, he's displayed none of those
things.
I have to go and I have to go and rewatch it that Turkey interview.
But it's like it's like so strange that she works with this guy
now. >> No bizarre because they don't really
>> It's bizarre if you hold her to her words. If you hold
her to her actions, which is she is like a shameless social climber
who will always be nice to people who are nice to her and have
clout no matter what, then it makes total sense. But if you look
at her and like try to hold her to her words, then then like
she's a total failure. She doesn't hold to her own morals or
beliefs whatsoever in good faith, you >> Um like are they
okay? I mean that's the
Yeah. I mean they're like Ogre Boy, you know. They're hate watchers.
Like like Ogre Boy is a fan of Jstalk. So it's like you know
like that just >> That's true. Ogre Boy often tells me
he looks up to me. Ogre Boy has shown me several concepts for
a Jtock tattoo. I've not okayed any of them yet. But he has shown
me several concepts. Okay. He is getting the tattoo. He's getting
the tattoo very soon. I've heard this ogre boy in chat right
now saying nah nah nah nah that. It's pretty sundere of him if
you're going to ask me. Okay. It's pretty sundere. >> Gives
you as much information as you need. Right. Like the thing is
is >> wait wait wait. >> What was that? They're hate
watched.
>> They're hate watchers that gives you as much information
as you need.
>> I mean, watching with a critical lens, like I'll get
I'll get into like narrative sometime and be funny. >> Watchers.
Yeah. I mean, they're like Ogre Boy, you know? They're hate watchers.
Like like Ogre Boy is a fan of J Stelk. So, it's like, you know,
like that just gives you as much information as you need, right?
Like the thing is >> Oh, right. That's what she said. We
paused there. Ogre boy is a fan of JT Stoke. That gives you much
as much information as you need. Apparently, Ogre Boy, you are
going to be judged for chatting here and watching this, okay?
Automatically is >> they missed the Willy M. No, this leads
into the Willy Mack stuff. You didn't miss it, Gentle Will. We'll
get into it. >> There's this entire like coalition on the
internet right now who is out there to get Destiny's ass. Um,
and they're like fully anti- Destiny. And if they view you as
a person who doesn't condemn Destiny enough on your stream, like
they are they think that they you are aligned with Destiny even
though you have explicitly said no, that's not true. That's not
true at all. If somebody doesn't condemn Destiny, as in they
don't state the things he's done or if they make like a if they
come to a conclusion that's wildly like disjoint from the facts,
I'll point out how it's disjoint. I very rarely, unless I have
a solid read on somebody, ever say, "Oh, this means you're like
destiny aligned." But this is this is a very important part,
okay? Because this sort of this is the part where I feel like
you can spin off into the Willy Mac stuff because she's about
to mention it, right? >> Destiny has done a great wrong
and you're bothered by it. So, it's like it makes no sense. >> Yeah,
that seems a bit silly.
>> Who have I got what what independent content creator
who didn't have a relationship with Destiny have I gone to and
said, "Oh, you won't condemn Destiny? You suck." Right? There
are some people who are very close to Destiny that I personally
was like, if you don't really make any statement on this at all,
I'd feel weird. >> So that's why they hate you. That's
why they dislike you and hate watch you is
>> I've never once watched Hutch. So I the only Hutch content
I'd ever watched was all after or sorry, all before I found out
that he was that he said the thing about Destiny, the whole like,
"Oh, I really regret commenting on the situation." It had nothing.
And for whatever his stuff was before, I didn't even know what
it was. I had no idea.
is because you're somebody >> like sorry whatever he said
about Destiny before that comment I didn't even have any idea
what his position was I think I knew that he was distanced but
I don't think I knew anything specific >> the who has apparent
like apparently you condemn Destiny maybe once a month versus
every day that they would consider to be a good enough frequency
for them to accept
>> panub do you do you think I needed people to condemn
Destiny every day or every week instead of every month I it's
never been like that ever that's just >> sad Trust me.
>> Really? Like this is this >> Oh, apparently this
is Hutch speaking on Destiny. Hold on. Let's see. Let's see what
it says. >> Let's see what it says. >> Sorry, I had
to blow my nose. I I don't know if you >> You need to do
that. You need to unmute it and keep it like camera on when you
do that. No, I'm just kidding. Um
P uh Pixie, content creator that we are all familiar with, made
allegations about another content creator that we all know and
have collaborated with, Destiny, that he shared uh non-consensual
images, explicit images of her non-consensual.
>> Um, and there's litigation going on right now, so it's
pretty complicated as far as that goes, but we've been asked
to talk about it. So, we're going to very quickly address it
and then move on to what the topic of live and learn is, which
is politics, which is our our millu. So, now I personally um
when I watched this the first time didn't really like that Josiah
left out the the explicit cherry allegation there, right? I didn't
I didn't like that personally. So, I'm going to point it out
again now that I just I really dislike that they left that out
entirely.
Um, it it feels very bizarre to me to to be honest with you.
>> Um, I don't know who wants to go first, >> given
the the friendship, but hey. Hey, >> get away first. >> Yeah.
Peace.
>> That's a while back. Okay. That's a while back. >> Yeah.
So, first of all, thank you for introducing it. Um, obviously,
you know, I'm very good friends with Stephen. I'm also met Pixie
um in Miami. I thought that it was, you know, great conversations.
Going to go get dinner. Um it sounds like there's been a lot
of um really bad damage that potentially has occurred that these
leaks and um situations have been very >> Did Did Pisco
say he was about to go get dinner with her? >> That these
leaks in Miami? I thought that it was, you know, conversations
>> that he'd met her in Miami. Right. Right. Right. Right.
It sounds like there's been a lot of um >> really bad damage
that potentially has occurred. Um that >> Pisco made a
better statement on this on his stream. >> These leaks
and um situations have been very very impactful.
But the reason I'm being ky is because I'm a lawyer. I know these
people and it is certainly not appropriate for me to talk about
it given my position at the time. And I like just being 100%
real with you guys. You're not going to bully me to give a more,
you know, uh, subjective statement about my beliefs on on this.
And so definitely not going to get into the >> Yeah. You
want me to go? >> Yeah, sure. I mean, um, I guess Hutch
and I are a little bit as well, a little bit more detached from
the situation than Pisco. I mean, look, I I I read as much as
I could. Um, similar to what Pisco said with a some sort of vague
amount of legal situations going on. I mean, I guess we'll probably
get more information about this eventually to come to a more
uh concrete opinion of it. Um, but
>> uh, no, I think you can have a totally you can have
a totally concrete opinion on it, right? You can have a totally
concrete opinion on this right now. Like you can look at the
evidence and what's admitted to. Uh, but that's fine. They just
they don't want to look at like this is basically one of those
things where they're like, "Oh, that could be really bad. I'm
going to not look at it at all." This is better than nothing,
right? Like, hey, I'm going to totally disassociate from this
because I don't have I'm not going to take the time to look into
it. I'm not going to say anybody's wrong. And that's how you
have to look at it, right? They're just totally disassociating.
If Econo Boy had a very close relationship to Pixar Cherry, I
would find that weird, like really weird on his part, but I don't
know if he had a particularly close relationship to either of
them. So, if he wants to totally if he wants to like disconnect
and just say, I'm not looking at any of this. Uh, somebody will
figure out what it is and then I'll I'll know then. It's like,
okay, that's like less bad than that's less bad than some other
>> obviously. Look, a total just complete sympathy for
Pixie. um you know anybody who's ever known anybody who's been
the victim of reven however it originates you know just however
you know people gets leaked onto the internet um it's obviously
a really terrible situation and you know I have no reason to
doubt that she's gone through a lot of anguish with regards to
the situation and so tons of sympathy for her um with regards
to Destiny specifically I mean look you know in so far as you
know if he was sharing nudes with people without their consent
that's just obviously super up um but we don't necessarily know
um all the details about it um and I don't I don't want to >> all
the details were known at this point but it's fine >> have
like an outsized um strong opinion on it without all the Um,
so unfortunately this is just one of those things like you have
to wait like a year or more depending on the pending legal stuff.
>> They're just waiting for the court case to end and if
Tiny gets off they will take that as nothing happened and back
on the gravy train. I don't think that's true for a couple of
these people.
I you'd have to you'd have to split it up in between them. Um,
Pisco, I don't believe that's true. Josiah, I don't believe that's
true. I think they would probably be willing to argue with with
Destiny on things, but I don't think they'd be like totally back
in that orbit nearly. see all the >> um Pisco I've seen
like a lot more like Pisco I might have had a different like
opinion of maybe 6 months ago. I think at this point I can see
where his opinions come from. I can see how that's kind of my
thoughts on it. You know it happened today. There's just not
a lot of information about it. Um sympathy for Pixie. Um you
know obviously if anybody shares anybody's news uncontentually
that's really condemnable and that's kind of how I feel about
it overall. Um you know that's all I really have to >> I'll
just say again um my heart goes out to Pixie. I can't possibly
imagine what this must feel like. Um,
my heart breaks for her. Sharing images, explicit images and
videos of somebody non-conensually is supered up. Um, and if
that's what happened, that should be just openly condemned. It's
just it's that's soed up. Um, >> so now now we know for
a fact that this did happen, right? >> I don't even know
what else there is to say on this. Again, I know there's >> like
Destiny has testified that he's done this. >> My understanding
is there's litigation. I know one way, maybe both ways. I I'm
not sure about like the legal intricacies, but uh again, non-conensually
sharing images of like explicit images and videos of people.
Super up. My heart breaks for her. Um, Hutch, what about you?
>> Yeah, we spoke about it briefly before the stream and
I told you that
>> if you met her in person, she's just such a sweet, pleasant
person. I've never had a bad interaction with her. You made the
point that even if she was a terrible person, it would be up
and I agree. But it's just it it is that much kind of >> more
difficult because she is so sweet. And so I think there's a lot
that we don't know about what has transpired and we'll learn
more information as the facts emerge. But I >> So here's
here's the unfortunate thing is or the unfortunate thing, yeah,
I'm not totally sure. There are things that have happened, right,
that won't be included in the court case or won't really be evaluated
by the court. So that makes this difficult for you could say,
"Oh, well, I will look at the court case and make my decision
from that." Well, that is only one of several of the allegations
and there's evidence of the other allegations all over the place,
right? So you're basically you're basically going to try not
to look. Now, I would say that if any of them were to go back,
if if people do like flock back to Destiny, let's say let's say
Pixie's case gets dismissed and a bunch of people flock back
to Destiny, right? I would say then if somebody else sues and
wins a case, anybody who disavows at that point looks very silly.
Looks very, very silly, right? And a whole bunch of other people
have cases in this way. And if he's criminally charged with regards
to the cherry stuff or anything else he's done, I think if they
disavow then if they were to go back and then disavow again,
that would be very embarrassing. I I don't think I could take
any of them seriously if that happened. Right. That's that's
my opinion. You know, that's me trying to be dispassionate. Look
at it as a third party. Like, okay, you could say this, but like
a lot of the information is out there. If you go back, I think
basically you were just bending to to like public pressure in
the first place that you didn't have like a principle here. You
were just bending to public pressure. I think what we do know
right now is that >> fairly sure Destiny said he has he
wants nothing to do with any of these people anymore. Yeah, I
don't believe him. >> Her privacy seems to have been violated
in a way that she's going to have to deal with for the rest of
her life. And the stress that she's going through right now is
could be transformative um for her forever. And so like you I
don't think we can really underplay the significance of that
kind of violation. >> Oh wait, Hutch has the best take
by far. What does he disagree with here now? Wait, what is he
what is he saying? I wish I didn't say this.
I'm confused. >> So, I feel really bad for her. I'm going
to wait for more information, but I think she uh I think she
deserves some support right now. So, yeah, >> 100%. Yeah.
Um so, that's that. Um that's all we're going to discuss about
it on this stream. Um in the world of politics, a lot happened
today. Uh again, before >> Yeah. I don't I don't particularly
like the people who are like, "Oh, it has to be a court case
to like talk about it." I just don't I don't particularly like
that. But I understand it. It It gives you like an easier thing
as a content creator if you like can just put that person to
the side.
>> 45th president of the United States became the 47th
accountable your camera. >> Okay. We're all done with that.
All
>> So he wishes he hadn't hadn't commented. We're going
to get back to Hutchin Food Shops talking. Okay. >> Okay.
Okay. Not literally not theming maybe once a month versus every
day >> that they would consider to be a good enough frequency
for them to accept. It's as silly as that. Trust me. >> Really?
Like this is this is >> Yeah. Insane. I totally believe
that he said that. I believe you that he said that. I don't believe
that. >> It's kind of silly. >> Okay. Okay. Not literally.
Not literally, but like they went Okay. You know Willie Mack,
right?
>> Okay. You know that Willie See, this is one thing that's
very weird to deal with is I've got like a bunch of weirdos who
like go and say, "Okay, who's in the audience at this Jtock stream,
right?" Like like people who are like going to go around and
malign me in different CH. It's so goofy. Losers, man. Losers.
>> Okay. You know Willie Mack, right?
>> Weird weird stuff. >> You know that Willie Mack
has made anti-destiny videos, right? >> Yeah, I reacted
to one of them, I think. >> Okay.
Would you say that Willie Mack is someone who has >> uh
Not that that comment was an example of that. I saw another comment
about that. It's fine. >> No, I don't think so. >> So,
here's the thing. Okay. They cons >> would you say Willie
Mack is pro Destiny? Now I wouldn't say that I was saying Willie
Mack was overtly pro Destiny. I said he was probably, you know,
enthralled to the Destiny audience in a lot of ways and that
made it difficult for him to make like objective decisions. A
lot of his money, a lot of his audience has come from basically
replatforming Destiny r/ Destiny thread and r/ Destiny posts
one to one, right? And so it's probably very difficult for him
to make a solid take there.
I I I don't think at this time, you know, I would have said he
was pro Destiny at
Little maybe a little different. Listen, maybe a little different
now when we take all things together in totality. Okay. But we'll
we'll get to Mac to be pro Destiny
because he has not condemned Destiny enough or they didn't condemn
Destiny in a way that they specifically
>> Does that make sense? >> Well, that's No, it doesn't.
But I mean, it's it's consistent behavior. Like, um, I've I've
noticed that they use Destiny as a >> a method to try to
discredit people. That's just the and I feel like they do that
when they're not, >> especially when they're not super
comfortable with the argument or engaging in the substance of
what you're talking about. >> Max videos are anti-destiny,
huh? That's a stupid food shops take. I would say
the thing about Willy's videos is they are needlessly like um
they needlessly like spread the targets out. they needlessly
they like don't follow like an overall narrative like an overall
character judgment very well right like there's a overarching
pattern of behavior to Destiny's entire career with regards to
um like negative social action negative um
behaviors negative behaviors and if you don't tell that entire
story I think it's a fairly weak video in my opinion >> they'll
just deflect to Destiny as if that's relevant like the Vanguard
guys did that and uh it's uh I just I don't really like let it
spot need too much to be honest cuz I just don't I find it pretty
ridiculous. Um >> Okay. I think that's I don't know how
much else we get here. >> Um you don't mind if I ask a
few questions, do I? Do you? >> Oh, that's fine. Yeah.
>> Okay. Uh you once did gaming streams,
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> What What made you turn to politics?
What's up with that? >> I've always been interested in
politics. >> Miners are attractive is also a stupid food
shops take. That That is true. >> So, um >> I was
I was eight. >> They believe that one though. They believe
that one from the bottom of their soul. when >> you don't
you don't give that opinion online unless you're willing to,
you know, stake your entire reputation and soul on it. Okay.
>> 911 happened. Um, and so that was the thing that like
I was never a good student in high school. I I kind of messed
around a lot. Um, I was like good at Spanish and a couple other
subjects, but I didn't really care much for history and and uh
when 911 happened, I got really self-conscious. I was in college
and this thing happened and I had no idea about like
>> Jto isn't a politics streamer. He's just like a Chud
logic. Wow. >> I had no idea why it happened. I didn't
know anything about domestic politics, let alone, you know, geop
geopolitics. And so that was the thing that got me interested
in politics. I I switched majors to sociology. And then I um
I became really really interested in in history and philosophy.
And so I just I spent a lot of time reading Nam Chomsky and Howard
Zinn and uh Oh no. And uh you know Michael Moore and so I was
actually
>> Yeah. Yeah. I was a bit of a leftist when I was uh when
I was in my 20s. And >> Right. Right. Okay. >> And
then so you know but uh Bush lost re-election or I'm sorry he
won re-election in 2004 and I was so personally devastated by
that but that I just kind of checked out of politics for a bit
and uh and when Trump and that's when I built up the YouTube
channel around gaming. Um and then when Trump came along he really
and Bernie too. It was like a one-two punch when they came along
in 2015 and 16 and uh kicked off a lot of that discourse the
gaming stream politics than when I was playing games. So I was
like >> I'm trying to I'm trying to get through the I don't
care question like what I'm >> Okay. Do you
>> uh do you have a what so is that the direction you want
to take your channel? I guess cuz you got a lot of
>> So Hutch is trying to go in an anti-lefty direction.
That's like that broadly his big contention. One of his big contentions
with his co-hosts on his on his podcast, Live and Learn, is he
believes punching left is productive and Pisco, Josiah, and Okonnell
Boy all believe that punching left is broadly not productive.
Uh, I would possibly agree with with Hutch that punching left
can be important. You should police your own side so you don't
like let things get out of hand, but you have to be very careful
with it, right? You have to be very careful. You have to make
like um
I don't know. You have you have to be very careful, very intentful
with it. You shouldn't just be like loading up your stream being
like, "How can I how can I make Hassan bad today?" That's probably
not a goal. And I don't think Hutch is careful based on the conversation
with with Ogre Boy, right? Like I think he basically, and I've
seen this now, I feel like a couple times where Hutch takes like
the generalized leftist and complains about them instead of engaging
with the person he's talking to, right? He will take opinions
that far leftists have. Uh Hassan does suck, but that's not that's
not the point of that statement. Forgotten Jones, you just got
to you kind of just got blinders on. It's fine. You didn't hear
me. It's okay. I said the word I know when I say the word Hassan,
some people are just
Hassan sucks. Hassan sucks. That was not the point of the the
comment at all, but it's fine. Okay. Um Hassan is bad. Asan is
bad. Jesus Christ, guys. Okay, chill. Chill with the Hassan is
bads for a second. So, I think Hutch will sometimes just take
the generic lefty, right? And he will he'll apply a bunch of
labels and a bunch of beliefs to them without just talking to
them normally, right?
>> Okay. I I can't tell if you're in the algorithm or not
because it seems like your subscriber count has been stagnant
and I promise I don't mean this in a bad way whatsoever. Um has
remained rather stagnant. Obviously, you still get a good number
of viewers when you are streaming like maybe 200 300 or so, right?
Um reasonable to say 400. Um >> that's on that's on Twitch.
On YouTube, it's up like it's usually between like 600 700. So,
collectively, it's like around 1,000. Yeah. 1,300.
>> are you are you still getting a lot of
>> I don't check those metrics. I like a long time ago.
Um, so like I wasn't I actually stopped posting on YouTube altogether
for two years and then just did a complete >> Wait, why
why in the world would you just stop checking your metrics? >> A
complete rebrand back in like it was about a year ago in August
of last year. And uh we I I picked up an editor and uh and uh
so I just don't even look at the YouTube VOD stuff like and the
editor keeps all the money for the revenue for all these videos.
It's for me it's just about like driving traffic to the streams
and kind of like and then if it can turn into something like
more in the future that's that's good obviously but that's not
really like focusing on the VOD that focuses on like feeding
the live stream stuff. No, no. I I I totally agree with you.
And in it, you know, in a way, the subscriber count doesn't really
mean anything when you're a streamer, right? Because when you're
a streamer, um, you want to know how many people you can capture
at any one given moment, right? So, I totally get that part.
Yeah. Um, >> you check your metrics lock. >> video
froze. This is a VOD. This is my VOD that paused because I'm
also the editor. Like, I don't really have a separate person
to edit like my VODs. Like I have to clip out the segments um
myself and like group feed my viewers like 20-minute videos.
But, you know, >> well, when you first start out, like
when I first started out, this was like 16 years ago, >> talking
about it
every day and cool to watch it grow and stuff like that. And
then just after a while I think it gets kind of um it can >> J
said that he wouldn't talk to his son. Ask him about that. Okay.
Where do I That's possible. I don't know. Did I say that that
I wouldn't talk to >> healthy to like like just be looking
at these numbers all the time and and so I just decided I just
don't really pay that much. I just try to focus on like making
good stuff and if I make good stuff then I'm reasonably confident
that people will come and watch. So yeah. >> Yeah. Yeah.
Um do you Okay. Okay. Spicy spicier question. Okay. If Hassan
ever hit you up for a chat, would you be up to chatting with
Hassan on stream? >> Yeah, probably. >> I said Hutch
wouldn't talk to Hassan. I might have said he'd get his blown
out by Hassan, but that would shock me if I said he wouldn't
talk to Hassan.
>> Why would I say that? I actually don't know why. Maybe
I did, but why would I say that? Because I think that I I think
at some point I'm not sure if I misheard it or not, but when
we were view reviewing JTO covering you, okay. Um I think JOK
said at some point um he he implied that if Hassan hit you up
that you would not accept a talk with Hassan. What does I feel
like somebody here would remember that? No. Wouldn't somebody
in chat remember me saying that? I have no idea. Where would
I have said that? Where where would I have said that like ever?
Yeah. I don't I just I don't know why I would say that >> because
he doesn't want to join. is like a massive opportunity >> a
coalition or something. I I don't know. Something something along
the lines that I'm not sure if I
>> Oh, food chops his
and half asleep most of the time they stream. So, they're probably
referring to me saying that like Hutch doesn't want Hassan in
the coalition. Hassan is bad. We can't have Hassan in the coalition,
right? So, it's probably not that probably wouldn't talk to him
about joining the coalition. Something along those lines. No,
no, no. in terms of shrink caught that he absolutely would talk
to him >> bringing or not but yeah that's just one of the
conclusions I came to okay um do you okay you ready for a spicier
question than that
>> that wasn't that spicy >> I know it was >> Joab's
going to love that you're covering this I just think it's very
very very funny that
Hutch was like I can't talk to Quean but I will go talk to >> that's
why I see >> or at least somebody somebody who's aware
of Hutch's schedule is like no you can't go talk to Quean
then he's food shops and they're like, "Yeah, I got no problem.
I'm not going to say anything." >> Okay. All right. Um,
would you be willing to rebuild the bridge of >> I try
not to take really absolutist positions on anything. Um,
>> I think, you know, I think the short answer that to
that would be, yeah, but
>> it really just depends on a lot of things. Like I want
to see more information come out during this trial. Um, I've
had people privately reach out and relay um, things to try to
like dissuade me from >> Yeah, this is where we saw that.
Yeah, privately dissuade him from talking to >> Uh, building
any kind of bridge like uh, to be honest with you, I don't know
if that bridge is still open. He ended up like blocking me on
Twitter. I'm not exactly sure why. It might have been cuz I reacted
to a Willy Mack video. U, >> I'll tell you why. I'll tell
you why actually. Um it's because he explicitly said during stream
at some point that uh
>> comfortable chatting and debating with right-wingers
but not with leftists.
Oh yeah yeah yeah exactly. So he Hutch will talk to somebody.
This is what Ogre boy is complaining about, right? Hey, you'll
go talk to like Rob No, but like lefties are so evil, right?
And I do think Hutch sees it that way that like oh I can go talk
to those people but I I have to make sure we we like purity test
these people out. And it's the whole idea that we're going to
purity test these people, the the far lefties out while also
saying purity testing is what is ruining the Democratic party.
It's like a weird It's a weird double standard that goes on this
very
>> You he claimed that you said in 5 years only in 5 years
that you would forgive Destiny and Destiny said that. So I don't
want Hush to come back so Hutch. >> That's what I think
that's what Destiny said. Yeah. Like >> apparently this
is the clip here. Hold on one second. Oh, I see. No, no, no.
I see what he's saying. I see what he's
>> he's going to roll this into like a total criticism
of like >> why is Hassan so bad when you know like Hassan
can help you? Hassan can be like like you're willing to talk
to conservative over time, right? You're willing to go oh this
is me hypothesizing what I think Ogre boy's argument is going
to be. Oh, but the So Jobs doesn't really pay attention to streams.
Probably neither does her audience, right? So she wouldn't have
seen that I'm hypothesizing what Ogre Boy's argument is going
to be. I'm not making my own claim here. This is me hypothesizing
on what ogre boy is going to say, like what his overall criticism
is going to be. I also think this is wrong. I don't know if Ogre
Boy nor right. No, no, no. I don't think I think the argument
here sprigs is going to be something along these lines. Why the
>> I haven't watched forward, but we did watch that little
clip. Why the Yeah. Okay. This is a hypothetical me thinking
through another person's Okay. All
>> Oh, you didn't say that or didn't imply. Oh, someone
in my No, >> no, someone in my chat asked me like
someone in my chat asked me the same question. Would you ever
>> rebuild that bridge? And
>> okay, so from this, I don't think there's much more
with Hutch here.
I can't recall if there's more to this. From here, I'm gonna
probably start going over to the Willyax stuff. Right.